from un's secretary general the warning
was dire
further escalation of the war whether by
accident or design
threatens all of humanity the prospect
of nuclear conflict once unthinkable
is now back within the realm of
possibility
and yet as russia's brutal campaign of
violence against the people of ukraine
intensifies worries that the war could
escalate into a global conflict are
growing
following reports that russia asked
china for military and economic
assistance something the kremlin denies
u.s national security adviser jake
sullivan met with a top chinese official
monday in rome it was an intense seven
session reflecting the gravity of the
moment we will not allow any country uh
to compensate russia uh for its losses
it would be a very significant and
meaningful move if china were to switch
from sort of its position of you know
kind of benign
neutrality towards russia to actively
supporting them in any different way in
part because imposing the same level of
economic sanctions against china would
be much more painful for the west still
backing russia would not be without
consequence if china wants to be a
worldwide pariah they'll back russia the
chinese are too smart to do that but the
fact that russia is asking means that
they're desperate i i think that
vladimir putin's back is up against a
wall russian forces may have encountered
more resistance in ukraine than the
russian president had anticipated but
russian forces are slowly gaining ground
it's why ukraine's president continues
to call for more support repeating his
request to nato for a no-fly zone
the white house will now be watching
china's next steps carefully it says
that while china makes up almost 20
percent of the global economy g7
countries account for more than 50
percent the biden administration warning
china there will be consequences should
it choose to help russia in any way
david
heather yorks west in washington thank
you